jane slater nfl network
reporter you can see her on nfl
network's nfl now today at uh 1 eastern
her
twitter is at slater nfl jane joins us
now
it's happy dak prescott today uh jane
how are you going to celebrate
you know waking up early because you
never know as the cowboys typically say
their door is always open for deals but
i can confirm that they have not had
any talks or negotiations with todd
france dax agent so
i think we're less than a little less
than six hours now till this deadline 3
pm here central time
uh does look like we're moving towards
the franchise tag on this one
if we looked at the offer with the
cowboys is this a fair
offer or is it you know how is it viewed
league wise i guess it depends on who
you ask dan
now the cowboys consider it a fair offer
if you look at the numbers they're
looking at anywhere between i was told
about 33
35 million dollars and then the
guarantee is closer to jared goff so
it's over 100 million
it's probably right around that 110
million dollar number and then as for
total guarantee
i'm told it's the guarantee is about 85
plus it's a rolling guarantee something
that they do these days but then it's
all guaranteed so
if you look at the money it's of course
not bad for a guy who's
been paid less than five million uh to
play for the cowboys he was that fourth
round pick i always remind people
behind jamil showers and of uh of course
tony romo when tony romo went down uh
but he feels that he can get the 31.4
this year
next year if they franchise tag him
again he gets 37 million
and then of course when they're looking
at that third year which is really the
sticking point for them
both in this contract and then the
contract after a second franchise tag
that's when they're expecting the
gambling revenue to go up the tv
contracts to spike
and that's when when dak's agent really
wants to cash in for his client
and i wondered this and i wanted to ask
you the question can you see
maybe a situation where dak moves on
from the cowboys
i don't think it's gotten to that point
yet dan i mean i just keep going back to
when he was a rookie the way that he
galvanized that locker room this was
tony romo's city this was his team it
was his franchise
not only when he came back was he not
allowed to compete for the job
it practically forced tony under
retirement of course he's seen a lot of
success now
uh in the broadcasting booth which i do
have to apologize
i remember saying on your show he was
going to struggle in the booth and he
certainly
did not and he got paid handsomely so
look we've all got to eat crow when we
have a bad take that was a terrible take
by me a couple years
i didn't even remember it jane but thank
you for bringing that
up i like to keep myself honest here dan
but
dak has done such a good job both on and
off the field now i know people have
gotten to dak and they've tried to
encourage him that
look you take this deal because you
don't know what the economy is going to
look like
also i should bring up i was talking to
a couple of agents because i was pulling
them in other words what would you do
and they're sort of as split as the fan
base is on this
but one agent reminded me of anthony
spencer's deal he was franchise tagged
when he was a young lineman they thought
that he was going to have a lot of
success the last year so they rolled the
dice
he didn't play as well and they didn't
have a great year in fact the cowboys
weren't going to franchise tag him
they ended up tagging him again he
injured himself in the third game
and then looking back in hindsight
probably wish that he had had the
security
of a longer term deal dak has just
always been a guy
that has banked on himself he's been
pretty durable he's played 64
regular season games he's gotten them to
three playoffs he's won one
this is a guy that from high school to
college to even the league has always
been himself
i always talk about his history which is
interesting he's always replaced the
starter because of injury and never
given the job back
and then everyone always asks me well is
this going to be a distraction well it
certainly wasn't a distraction last
season
and this is the guy that's played
through his mother being sick he played
with tony romo
breathing over his shoulder and and won
the job and
the cowboys didn't look back since he
does an amazing job of
compartmentalizing but what he's doing
here is he's banking on himself and
trying to get max value
is she a great quarterback you know if
you ask his teammates they'll tell you
he's a great quarterback and i think
there's a lot of things that come with
me a great quarterback
are you a true leader do you galvanize
the locker room and in terms of the
intangibles
they brought in john kitten last year of
course he's not here this year with the
staff
they of course brought in a whole new
coaching staff that he really hasn't had
a chance to familiarize
himself with because of covid and
virtual otas and the holdout
but i've been told within that building
mike mccarthy from
what he saw is rookie season when he
came up there and he beat the packers
which
i would argue was one of the one things
that was sort of
in jerry's crawl space when he was
trying to decide romo or dak it was the
way he went up there
he led that team to victory mike
mccarthy remembers that he's mentioned
that
i've been told that he thinks that he
can do great things uh
with dak prescott that this is the guy
that you want and then you look at his
gaudy passing numbers last year i mean
he certainly
answered all the critics who said he
couldn't throw the ball uh he's time and
time again i sort of answered a lot of
the questions
it is a little frustrating i think
probably for him
that this is a team that is famously
overpaid players
that has never let a contract like this
get down
to the wire you've just got a really
shrewd businessman
and todd france negotiating this
contract and you finally have the
cowboys saying we're gonna be smarter
about the way that we do these deals
and that's why we're at this impasse the
cowboys want a five-year deal
he wants a four-year deal i keep asking
the two sides so just get the four-year
deal done
uh the argument is they want to tear
that that deal up
in year three and then like i said
capitalize on that growing cap and the
revenue
and the cowboys feel like they are
paying him top of the market money
they front load these contracts they
believe they should get that extra year
because they believe that this is a fair
offer
i have more of a problem with ezekiel
elliot's contract than i do what you're
gonna pay dak prescott
like i i don't i didn't understand when
you
resign a running back i want you for
four or five years
and then i move on you're you're all
interchangeable it feels like
quarterback it's different you know to
your point dan
the cowboys were pretty solid on that
saying that he didn't
todd gurley didn't deserve todd gurley
money and this thing got pretty
acrimonious and it was
i i didn't go to bed on this one either
because i knew someone was going to pick
up the phone
in that case rocky arsenault his agent
picked up the phone
zeke came back from cabo he had what i
call fomo he wanted to be around his
teammates they were able to get the deal
done
but i would also argue that because of
todd gurley's contract and his equals
contract you got to think the next
running back may not get top of the
market value
because you haven't seen a sort of
production uh and it goes back to all
the analysts who are saying you know
look the running back doesn't deserve
some of that money well todd gurley and
ezekiel elliott's contract certainly
didn't do the next running back any
favors
she's jane slater nfl network reporter
she didn't think tony romo would be any
good joining us here on the dan patrick
show
you know i was with you though i i
didn't because i'd never heard tony
be effusive and really uh you know
dramatic and
and opinionated and he's different and i
had somebody who said
man he killed his uh
rehearsal killed it and i went wow
okay what was it about romo that you
were
cautious about him being an analyst i
think it's tricky i think in this
business
to analyze your peers and so i thought
that that was something that
roma was going to struggle with but i
also think you and i have to admit
there's a narcissism and a bit of an ego
that comes with this job dan
and i think that that has sort of played
well for tony because you have to have
sort of confidence i've taught i've
heard that even when he goes into some
of these meeting rooms and he's talking
to coaches and the quarterbacks
he'll say so you think you're going to
do this particular play here and so
initially there was some eye rolling
about that
uh but i think there's now a respect
level for him and then i think of course
jim nance being paired with your match
you're sort of set up to succeed
uh but i think he's done a great job and
in fact look like i said i
own when i have bad takes i was doing an
event with tony at super bowl and i said
that to him i said look man
people were wrong about me and my career
and i appreciated when they owned up to
that so i owned up to tony and he
certainly got handsomely paid by cbs and
deservedly so
yeah nance plays such an unbelievable
role
in tony's success because tony is like
your little kid you know like my son who
just blurts out things
and then you kind of have to clean it up
and get it back you know
in in the middle of the road because
tony will be going watch your mother
watch tight end watch side in and
there's romo's back
dax back to pass so he gets to clean it
up but you know it's just one of those
kids who says something and uh and it's
fun
i just never saw that personality every
every bite that we had
every game he would say what was the
usual refrain paulie
when they lost a game i'm sad and
disappointed or seton did you have
frustrating disappointing frustrating
and disappointing every
we used to say know your romo like what
year what game did he say it because he
would always say
frustrating disappointing and i go
okay i can't see him as an analyst it's
like jay cutler oh do you have it here
it's just disappointing yeah yeah and
color's the same way
like i don't if color was way is on very
cavallari
that would be fun but i can't imagine
him going in there and lighting up a you
know an audition
cutler actually has a pretty amazing
personality when you get him away
the same i think a lot of these guys
sort of get conditioned and maybe we're
responsible for it dan in the media
they're sort of damned if they do damage
so they sort of refrain from saying too
much to us
but when you sort of get them off the
cuff and they get comfortable in that
booth i think troy aikman is one of the
best i love listening to try and know
some cowboy fans can't stand him they
feel like he's too harsh and i i find
his his criticism interesting i think
it's no different than
the way he was on the sidelines when we
watch a football life and we see him
mic'd up so
i do think a lot of these guys their
unique personalities come out
uh when you put them in the booth i
always felt bad for jason whitton i
think the reason why the jason witten
experiment failed was one i don't think
he was set up to succeed
with with the right teammates and i
think in our job too
i've certainly been cast with people
that makes maybe the chemistry's not
necessarily there
but i also feel like whitton is always
always
wants the the golden star and he's the
type of guy that has willed himself to
be good at his particular position
this sort of job i think comes with a
little bit of the reps but also sort of
like i said a little bit of the
narcissism and the ego and
jason's never really had that he's
always been a team first guy so
i think that's why jason and the jason
whitten experience
failed because he is such a talker i
find him interesting when you talk to
him it's just
it didn't work unfortunately in the
booth but do you think he'd still be in
the booth if he got good reviews
i do yeah i don't think he was one to
really go on social media either
uh he's one of those guys that that
ignored it and i know from my days in
sports talk
you've sort of developed a leather-like
skin
after a while you sort of shrug off uh
people's comments
and their thoughts dan i know everyone
thinks that they can do your job and and
not everybody can it's certainly a lot
harder than it looks but i think
probably jason also spent a little bit
too much time on social media caring
what people thought and i think that's
what gets
a lot of people in our line of work in
trouble when you worry a little bit too
much about
the people behind the keyboard i also
thought and i did reach out to him to
try to help him
because i said you you're a receiver
you're used to
waiting for the ball to come to you you
have to be a quarterback
when you do this you must see an attack
you can't wait and he just he kept
waiting but that's really his position
it's you may call on me four times a
game
but i have to wait and he wasn't he
didn't go after like romo steps up he
can't wait he's like a kid that's got
you know he's had you know four sodas
he's just so excited and
it can't wait to tell you what's going
to happen and even if he's wrong he
still
brings energy there and it's tricky and
i don't know if you look at like drew
brees got hired by nbc
is he a better studio analyst or do you
think would he be better in the
like certain guys can do the booth very
few can do the booth well
a lot of guys can do the studio and i
think that's always the tricky part
of who's the next person you see as an
analyst
an in-game analyst who's going to be
successful you know you bring up a good
point because
i think to your point we see brees sort
of talking off the cuff as he did with
the anthem situation
and how much it got him in trouble and i
i don't know if that makes you a little
bit more gun shy to sort of feel like
you can
put your opinion out there because you
see how quickly
there can be a backlash and and that
applies to your football take
that can apply to your political take
and some people
are capable of sort of going out there
and again i think there has to be an ego
and a narcissism behind it where you are
so
confident in what you're saying you're
not afraid of defending your position
so i i've always thought drew is sort of
the interesting one like i've
i love peyton manning peyton manning i
mean we even just saw that when
they did the golf tournament he's just
so good off the cuff
it's natural it's not contrived i think
cam jordan
if you're gonna look to the saints
locker room i've done
uh red carpet with him for nfl honors
he's amazing he's done a lot of this
stuff too
off to the side just on the ig story so
he's done a lot of stuff with us
i think he's studio though i think he's
studio jane
i think i think cam because you get more
opportunities there
and you you can tell stories there it's
hard to tell a story in a game
and i think cam has that personality i
want to see that personality too
i think phillip rivers might be sneaky
great in the booth i love philip reverse
i would love you know it's funny i
haven't actually heard his name really
tossed out there that much
he is so fun to watch even just has his
impassioned speech
leaving the chargers right uh i have so
much disrespect for him just as a human
when we did the pro bowl uh his
daughters had a daddy-daughter dance
and he flew all the way from orlando
back to san diego and then back again
for the game
because he wasn't going to miss his
daddy-daughter dance how he does all
those things and they had the
you know the outfitted van that took him
from san diego to l.a so
again that he he wasn't uh you know
removing his family from san diego
something they had gotten used to i just
i have a ton of respect for that guy and
to your point i could listen to him for
days and i would love to see him bring
back
uh the bolero i i loved that look i
think that the booth has been missing
that
i just want to get you on record does
the nfl season start on time
good question uh i was incredibly
optimistic
about it dan i know that those
conversations are still ongoing
i i can't tell you either way to be
completely honest i mean as reporters
we're having a meeting this week
uh discuss sort of what our assignments
look like what does travel look like
i didn't even think about it was brought
up to me here in texas and
i now considered in a hot spot state are
facilities that are not hot spots gonna
let me in
uh of course i cover the cowboys almost
99 of the time i have the titans in the
saints as well but
uh those are all these ongoing
discussions that are being had but to
your point i think a lot of people are
looking for some answers
as we get closer to the deadline but i
think those are still ongoing
it's great to talk to you again jane
great work and uh congrats on the
success with the nfl network
appreciate it thanks for having me on
dan that's jane slater nfl network
reporter